pour moi c'est un projet contre la peur
les moult fois une force
la directrice du musée des beaux-arts lé
bien compris exit la collection de
cultures du monde
il faut désormais parler des arts du
tout le monde c'est une référence à
edouard glissant qui est un poète et un
philosophe des caraïbes
c'est une vision d'un monde global
auquel nous appartenons au finalement
l'autre et n'est jamais un autre puisque
nous faisons tous partie de ce monde
ensemble on partage les mêmes peines les
mêmes joies
une approche qui tranche avec la vision
colonialiste qui avait cours au début du
20e siècle lorsque le musée des
beaux-arts a débuté sa collection
d'oeuvres venues d'un peu partout sur la
planète
c'est vrai que la vision auparavant
c'était plus une vision de
collectionnant on voulait donc posséder
le monde avec et au travers de ces
objets est tout un travail qui est fait
justement pour sortir de cette
perspective qui était extrêmement
occidentale au centre et dans cette
nouvelle aile des oeuvres venues
d'afrique cohabite avec l'art asiatique
des objets qui datent de l'antiquité
côtoient l'art contemporain quand on
regarde une neuf anciennes à côté d'une
oeuvre contemporaine
on voit des nouvelles choses qu'on n'a
pas perçu avant
de plus en plus les musées veulent
présenter une collection plus éthique
exemple de pillage dans une volonté de
dialogue avec toutes les communautés
descendante
on a fait la recherche sur la provenance
quand ces objets sont arrivés ici
comment ils sont arrivés ici est de
présenter ces informations là haut
publié au plus large public et après de
se mettre à l'écouté parce que c'est
clair que c'est on va pas se cacher
c'est le pourquoi on a toutes ses
collections là dans un musée occidental
c'est lié à l'histoire coloniale
le pavillon des arts du tout le monde
une façon de relire notre histoire avec
les lunettes du 21e siècle ici mais bien
alexandre chartier radio canada mme
royal